I don't think we should be pushing to
make gay marriage a normal thing I don't
think we should be celebrating gay
weddings look I don't think the police
are dying to waste a bunch of police
resources about what people are doing in
their bedroom this used to be a private
thing but now it is public and
celebrated and we have an entire month
dedicated to this I don't you know if
someone is gay everybody has a different
sin I'm not I'm not planning on spending
my day thinking about it it and in most
places in the world I would imagine
there are some gay people but they keep
it quiet and hush hush and do not wear
it on their sleeve